[Music]
I have a friend her name is Kate and
she's asking this sh I should have said
her name it's too late
um asking this question she's asking in
your late 30s or in your 40s is it still
sexy to be woken up in the middle of the
night with oral stimulation yes yes
always or is it are you asking a bunch
of dudes or or at this age is it
inconvenient and questionably unhygienic
depends who depends on who though and
what type of person you are really okay
let's start with you sex care if I was
sleeping with my partner and they woke
me up like that I'd be like but let's
say you guys were together let's say you
guys were together for like I don't know
six seven years you still feel the same
way hell yeah longterm relationship is
even more sexy you're like yeah cuz you
don't expect it as you got to keep the
spark alive I will say this though if we
just went to like [__] Disney World
and we went to like five different of
the kingdoms and we're walking around
and it's like 90° weather and we get
back and we fall asleep and then Nikki
wants to blow me in the middle of the
night I'd be like Yo dude no
way yeah yeah that's the prac there you
go that's the practical but what if what
if what if she already just started
doing it you woke up to it so it's
already happening would you be like stop
you mean no way as in like no or no way
as in like no way no way
dude yeah no it's I'm too I'm too
[__] tired dude really that's serious
thing that's a for real thing okay it's
like oh well yeah cuz if you're if
you're like mentally and physically
exhausted it's like you're just you're
out that's true what if you showered
before you went to sleep cuz I'm a
person that showers before I sleep so
hot that's why K's waking up so [__]
hot I just want to wake up in 5 hours
that about you K it's like I go to sleep
clean dude well that's like you know
just in case you get his dick I think
it's the idea of like you know when
you're you're um when you're not ready
to do it sometimes you got bad breath or
you you know you've been sweating or
something very true you know all of the
above are and then when you don't feel
sexy you kind of don't want sexy [__]
being done to you sometimes all of the
above are true I'm saying is like when
you're in like the honeymoon phase of a
relationship like you just started
dating it doesn't [__] matter if you
walked around five different kingdoms
and [__] because there's something about
the spice of like where it is so if it's
unhygienic then but you're down then
it's a mentality thing it's not a
physical I'm with I think it's um you're
turned on by how compelled they are oh
for them it's like they don't even care
about the situation or whatever it's
just at this moment this is what's the
most important even as long as like
you've been married to Gio if that was a
thing that occurred you would be like
always in it yeah like let's say she
knew had to give some crazy speech the
next day or crazy business meeting
whatever and like if the logical brain's
like [__] I got some important [__] to
do but the the first instinct is like
wow like this is how overcome You Are by
this feeling oh it's like a compliment
so and then after I go we need to be
responsible yeah dude you could shower
after hey that was really [__] of
you contest is key too because like if
you're like steveen Nikki and they're
boning all the time everywhere you just
have the best sex life ever stepping on
heads and [__] whereas like if you're
like a regular married dude and you're
just like man it's been a while and then
you just wake up to a
[__] you're going to be down in your
current state and relationship would
that be a a good thing make to real man
ask Nick yeah ask me would that be a uh
a welcome situation for you hez looking
you looking at me he's avoiding my
eyes so you're asking me yeah we're
asking you cuz I guess we're both
looking at you now I guess U part of me
would be like have you gotten
mad what you [__]
crazy did you did you spent all my money
and this is why you're doing this to me
[__] what's wrong what did you do what
hot dialogue each other are you mad
because it's so inconsistent with her
behavior n it's just like you know one
waking up in the middle of the night is
like for some people like you if I get W
woken up in the middle of the night it's
it's it can be startling or you're just
like not aware of the situation someone
better have broken in yeah something
something better be wrong you're on
flight mode well look dude you're in the
1800s dude you're like wife you Craven
Hound yeah you need to go to church
tomorrow what will the neighbors
think um no but of course I'm I'm in no
position at all to ever turn down
anything like
that after his
reaction man cuz but but that is the
duality of like so that's just dialogue
in his head yeah that's dialogue in my
head you outside of your mind but he's
just like
yeah no position I will let this
continue no but in your in your mind you
think like this is [__] ridiculous
like what is what do you doing dude dude
but but that's the turn on though for
people it's like but it goes back to
what what BART was saying like that's
crazy oh whoa whoa whoo out what's going
on yeah yeah yeah yeah you trying to hit
a record what's going on dude okay but
what's going on is going through your
head the whole time like what you know
but if I were to do that to her she'd be
like all right cut it
out hey should that cut out you're
missing the spot by the way I got wake
up that's not the clitus this
is like don't think different but then
you know I think girls are also more
self-conscious too than that's what it
is but if I'm more persistent and I just
say shut up lady let me do it and then
she'll be like okay and you have a
tongue piercing so you're doing it all
Instinct shut up lady once I start doing
the alphabet it's over bro you know what
I mean High what
dude sometimes I don't know what to do
when I'm down there it's like it's
overwhelming no do you make our contact
when you're down there I can't it's
try yeah you sneak a couple right a lot
of folks every now and then you're like
it's like it's like doing this yeah I
heard that if you break ey contact you
got start over yeah [__] go back to a
baby that's all I know so then
everybody's pretty you guys are are all
kind of in agreeance at like you talk
into a room full of dudes though yeah
that's just not this one of the only
times where I'm like yeah we need a
chick here too is she asking yeah is she
asking for like receiving it or well
she's probably K here what's her last
name
Kate here who was in her 40s a female
perspective let's see yeah call your mom
call her
up Mom Mom Mom you you ask question
about this Mom I have to ask yeah yeah
you ask you
Nick hi Gio oh hi I'm sorry hey ta
hi oh no do you still want me to ask a
question yeah code it code word cod cod
word in code in code we have a very
important question that we need a female
opinion because all the guys are
unanimous okay okay fine wait can ta
hear this question yeah yeah yeah yeah
in code in code in code it's going to be
in code okay okay
so what was a question
again he know he knows it he knows it he
knows it all right the question to a
strong start oh the question is um at
your 30s or
40s when you're
sleeping is it still a welcome thing if
you woke up to
oral stimul
intercourse fine I think oral is fine
yeah put it to the camera pass to taus
judging eyes like yeah he doesn't know
what it means what's Oral intercourse
even the dog's given us judging eyes
what's the question again oh my in your
30s or 40s okay there no code what what
is it still welcomed when you woke up
when you wake up to a surprise a
surprise to oral
surprise or do you consider it
unhygienic Etc or do you consider
unhygienic or inconvenient inconvenient
you're
tired the ladder you wouldn't want to
wake up to it no why explain yourself is
it cuz Bart sucks at
it that's why
all the reasons you listed on the second
go it's it's unhygienic it's
inconvenience it's just not wanted loser
quitter not want what about giving it
though oh yeah yeah what about yeah what
about you giving
it wait what about it like is it
inconvenient like do I want to do that
yeah and when why why aren you do you
think do you think Bart would find it
inconvenient or
unhygienic no he would be so into it he
yeah I think we have our answer
everybody and that's why we do bessels
with the boys not the girls yeah boo and
very straight I like it what we got out
of that is new merch unhygienic
inconvenient
unwanted get it a new t-shirt thank you
thank you bye thank you by ta thanks ta
thanks ta dude the fact that ta is right
there dude the whole time he's like Sak
you're talking about
mom what's Oral
inter what does he like is he just like
they're just saying nonsense what does
he think we'll do cold words on stuff
and he just doesn't even know he doesn't
even care yeah he's clocking it though
you better watch out it's it's probably
going to be like little alley oops that
get dunked 5 years later he goes oh
that's what they're talking
about oral surprise he's in college like
13 years from now he's like about to get
woken up he's like no no no no it's
inconvenient unhygienic and unwanted why
do I want
this inconvenient unhygienic dude the
best part was like we're going to do it
in code we're going to do it in code and
then you just asked the same exact
question no code nothing it's hard on
the spot dude the coding is hard you
were to receive
oral why even think about it oral is is
not a bad word oral is okay oral is okay
you don't want to be like go down what
about kangus straight up Kingus kangus
code Keling
istio yeah that's a good one see it's
just the all guy thing and yeah yeah
that really did show I bet there some
there's some ladies out there I think we
all knew the answer we knew that we knew
that and why did we ask her because we
wanted the audience to know that we hi
thinking here no hi mind JK [__]
good proof yeah from one person proof so
most girls yeah that really is like cuz
if it was up to me I don't even care if
she's on a period you know what I mean I
think that's the unhygienic part I I ate
at L's before and for those Reasons I'm
out I ate at L's before sometimes I've
never felt closer to Bart in my leg
sometimes prime prime rib is
incomparable I go little iron get that
beef and cheda But but so like but for
for her I'll be like oh she doesn't want
to do it in this or like I haven't
shaved in a long time or you know it's
just like uh there's little like excuses
they're quitters yeah so I could already
see like oh if the things aren't perfect
and you're not trying to I'm not trying
to get scientific but it's also a
difference with the physicality of it
you know what I mean there's like a with
the male penis the protrusion of it
makes it like easier to easier access
but here's the thing about bart is like
you're going to have to like spread and
get into something you got to wake her
up like this I can understand how that
hygienic part feels more like just
heightened for a woman I think I think
Joe well Joe you're not Joe you're Bart
I think I I meant to say Gio I think Gio
knows what kind of guy Bart is and I
think she knows that this guy's a rider
you know what I mean me so like she
shouldn't worry about this dude feeling
some type of way about eating the box at
like 3:00 a.m. in the morning you know
so I'm not a writer if she's on her
period though come on well like there's
there's a writer here Prett hard over
but then he's like if he's willing I've
never done it but I'm down because she
she's always she's always like I want to
so I'm like all right I don't care yeah
there's a riter and there's a Red Rover
he's a Red Rover some people are not
ready some people are all talk some
people think they're down but they're
they won't really be down I'm going to
go ahead and pretty much say I'm pretty
sure N9 out of 10 at least guys are down
do you think it's 10 out of 10 gay guys
oh yeah oh yeah gay guys are for sure
always they're probably waking up yeah
cuz there two [__] dudes holy [__]
dude gay guys probably wake up horny all
the time and they they probably wake up
doing it to each other and go oh oh wow
whoae calls it what L7 right L7 we
should call K and find
out
oh thought you were Joe
no call Tyler dude he'll know the answer
oh yeah let's call him call him call
him I don't know have so many lifelines
in this Tyler call Tyler Tao sit next to
him yeah what are you doing there ta see
let's really get Tyler's situation on
this cuz that's good Pro one gay
Lifeline here yeah that's good
proof I have Ty number no no he's like
no I must call it oh okay good hey but
use code use code yeah code code code
what's up hey what's up you're on JQ
news right now with the boys hey Tyler
dude hey you want a
FaceTime yeah that would have been just
FaceTime dud well I don't know he might
be he might be jerking off or something
dude G was with her [__]
son what's up buddy up dude what's up
dude all right we have a question for
you Tyler we just asked Gio the same
question now we need your perspective
okay are you ready all right in your 30s
or 40s encode encode he's not oh she's
he's young though is it more uh
acceptable or what is welcoming is it
more welcoming you welcome would you
welcome uh if you were asleep and you
were woken up in the middle of the night
by a surprise fellatio that's code he
doesn't need code he's [__] over 18
oral surpr if you were woken up by an
oral surprise use hand signs [__]
yeah use hand sign
it's like the the blow one yeah why are
we doing code with the grown man would
you consider that more careful than he
was with
ta would you consider that
inconvenient or okay unhygienic or and
unwanted or would you be like that's
cool um there is variables involved but
if it's from somebody that I love then
yeah the variable random person okay
hell yeah okay T was cool with it see
boom it yeah that's I think everybody
here is yeah except for Gio Gio's Gio's
a real bummer about
it all these stupid ass [__] all the
dudes are on the same page yeah dude all
right thank you Tyler
that's thanks
Tyler
dude who else should we call you don't
have to C it he's over
18 I still tried being all gentle with
his words so then
when you guys are asleep you you guys
are always in the default mood no no you
got rally look it takes work to Rally
but you you do it the guy has to work
very hard it's your [__] duty brother
you know what I mean if if if your lady
wants like I'm sure you guys have woken
up when your lady wants to like you know
do something get down a clown but you
don't hey whoa code code man
yeah [__] sometimes you there's times
where you don't want to do it where
you're just like are we really doing
this is this really
but then you take a couple seconds then
you go all right we're doing this and
you get
into between a man and a wife this is
the relationship this is the rules okay
if she wants it you give it if you want
it good luck yeah exactly that's how man
win I agree I 100% agree okay now let's
change the variables of the question all
right now change 30 to 40 to 60 to 70
look if your lady wants to have sex with
you and you turn her down you're
gay
ask Tyler ask call Tyler dude gay Tyler
and I think doesn't matter where you
move the Spectrum if you're a dude it's
yes all the way until you die yeah yes
to death so yes but I got to get my pump
you know what I mean like if it's if
it's no because of like an ailment like
you have the flu or something or [__]
you have like a crick in your neck and
you have Batman neck you can't turn your
head or something like that has that
ever happened to you where you had the
flu and you were like I don't want to
have sex and then I don't think anybody
body wants to have sex when they have
the flu but like you had to do it still
had to remember that Friends episode
with Monica and Chandler you did what
dude what are you talking about who's
this guy he's a black belt oh oh it's
Nick with a black no cuz I think like
you know going back to what you're
saying there's a difference between like
fully committing right and reciprocating
so even if you're like let's got the
craziest work week you're tired as [__]
and all that and then you wake up to it
think it's still like a and then you're
like I really can't you know but then
when you really can't and you're like
exhausted you go back to sleep you're
still thinking about the thought of that
was cool waking up to that oh but you
don't have to like finish anything you
trying to rev
it and you just you couldn't rev it to
where it needs to go yeah it was still
fun reving oh can I say something though
too I get you I think the frequency of
that act in the middle of the night is
also dependent on your likelihood to say
yes or no if it happens every [__]
night you be like all right bro what are
we doing can we do this during the day
can we open shop at
10 like why why are you choosing 3:00
a.m. every night like this is ridiculous
I got to work tomorrow also imagine if
it's the other way around where it's
like she wakes you up and she's like hey
hey hey can you give me oral stimulation
I'll be like that is
unhygienic
inconvenient oh [__] but then if if you
wake up the night you just feel your
head getting pushed down then where's
game dude that's game time cuz if you
turn down again you should you should
prob check who's doing that yeah just
pushing your head down all right dude
only chicks in movies dude only chicks
movies that doesn't happen that's what
you want no I don't want
it in the middle of the night by the way
I like that we called Tyler but we
didn't put any gay stipulation on it we
just asked him like another dude cuz
dudes are [__] dudes man dudes are
dudes that's why I knew it I knew it
yeah dudes are dud but we didn't want to
say that we knew we wanted to find out
for ourselves true yeah yeah cuz if you
put yeah we knew a I know what the
entire gay community thinks genius we
always go to Tyler for every gay
[Music]
question